hi I'm Erik Bosse the next step on our
Game of Thrones rewatch series singling
out epic game-changing moments is the
final scene of season 1 the birth of
Daenerys dragons something we can only
show you limited shots up here because
yeah there's a lot of skin in this show
you ever notice how all HBO shows are
trying to make us more okay with this
it's like they're turning the world into
a nudist colony good for you guys but
unfortunately for emilia clarke
Daenerys his birthday suit is actually
important to the story here this moment
isn't just a personal triumph for the
character it's her symbolic birth as the
series is true hero and interestingly
the closest match the show is provided
to the mystery of who is azor Ahai the
prince that was promised I'm gonna dig
deep in all this stuff
look back on the cool ways the series
led up to this moment and a few things
he might have missed the first time you
watched it and it should go without
saying
boilers ahead for all episodes of Game
of Thrones okay I should start by
reminding us all how shocking this
reveal was by now we've all been spoiled
by eye-popping visuals of full-grown
dragons torching armies and fleets and
giant ice walls
oh no the dragon call me when it turns
into a zombie but back in season one the
hatching of Danny's Dragons completely
changed the rules of magic in the world
of Game of Thrones sure that cold-open
introduced us to the existence of undead
white walkers a supernatural threat Jon
Snow's later scuffle with the white
proved to be legitimate but I would say
while the enemy up north remained a
mystery throughout season 1 this closing
image even more dramatically subverted
the assumptions of pretty much every
character on the show to this point that
the Targaryen dragons were gone never
coming back
dragon gone Khaleesi no dragon brave men
kill them it is known
he's known between these opening and
closing bookends it was easy to get lost
in the political drama between the
families but this closing shai reminds
us that these nasty people we've gotten
to know and love have actual epic forces
that they can unleash on each other
which like a baby with the bazooka is a
little terrifying
like any good shocker this moment works
because it both contradicts what
characters have promised us while paying
off the inevitability of the clues this
show is laid out for us so let's look at
those foreshadowing moments in my
analysis of Viserys is golden crown
moment episode 6 I pointed out how that
was a payoff of Danny's gradual
realization that she not her brother
possesses the blood of the Dragon and
thus cannot be burnt this power grows
within her while she develops an
obsession with her dragon eggs given her
by Illyria on her wet
the ages have turned them to stone but
they will always be beautiful as
Daenerys struggles to transition into a
Dothraki Khaleesi
these eggs provide her with strength she
stares at them almost hypnotically while
with Khal Drogo as if they contain the
reward of the struggle she has to go
through of course Khal Drogo's blood
thirst made him not long for this world
but he left Danny with very powerful
instinct the desire to be a mother so
when her experiment to bring him back
fails and she loses her baby
the Dragons must fill that void for her
if you look closely at the scene when
Jorah finds her in the ashes the dragons
are breastfeeding like newborn infants a
detail pulled directly from George RR
Martin's book now it's a little
unsettling because these dragons are
presumably reptiles not mammals but I
think it just speaks to the weirdly
biological connection between Danny and
her babies really her behavior here
almost seems like a form of postpartum
depression her function is that of a
mother now and she'll get her stallion
who mounts the world one way or another
but there are three details I really
liked about this sequence first is a
deviation from the books notice how
after a Drogo's funeral pyre burns out
Danny's skin and hair remain unburnt in
the books her hair mostly burns away but
the show left Danny's braid intact I
think this is because the way the show
used Danny's hair as her Dothraki Joe
Hawk the long braid Dothraki Warriors
wear that never gets cut unless they
lose in battle since this moment is
essentially a massive victory for Dany
it makes visual sense for her braids to
remain unsaid and to continue to grow
with complexity as a series goes on
another detail here is the music
composer Ramin Djawadi said that earlier
in season one the House Targaryen theme
plays in a few instances and it's hard
to pick up played with just one
instrument at a time like a cello but
later in this big finale javadi fills
the theme with instrumentation and
percussion including Japanese Tokyo
inspired drums an Indonesian hanging
drum called the bed dog and an Armenian
woodwind instrument called a duduk and
yeah I probably mispronounced some of
those and the end result of all this
instrumentation is a feeling that's
deeply primal and threatening
the third DTI notes in the sequence
involves Danny's fiery demeanor look at
her face as she condemns Miriam as der
to being burned to death it was not hear
me scream I will it's just not just
screams I would only your life the torch
light flickers on Danny's face giving
her a devilish quality this will be the
first of many times Danny uses fire like
this to bring vengeance on those who
have wronged her including her sack of
ass to pour her punishment of the
meereen slavers and her coup in Vaes
Dothrak in season 6 which is essentially
a recreation of this moment but I think
the most lasting effect of these final
shots is the way they answer the
supernatural threat presented in the
season's opening moments this is kind of
like a bell ringing in a boxing match in
one corner of the world humanity is
being threatened by ice meanwhile in the
opposite corner of the world a
potentially equal threat has arrived to
challenge it with fire it's just one of
the many examples of the motifs stemming
from the book series its name a song of
coldness and heat as know let's go I
can't read and if we look at the White
Walkers as a series as ultimate villains
this makes Dany the ultimate hero
actually looking back on this moment
pretty much everything here sets up
Danny as the prophesied azor Ahai reborn
also known as the prince that was
promised three years book readers
debated whether these two myths figures
were the same figure and now that
appears to be the case and it remains a
pretty big mystery on the show and in
the books but here's what they've told
us so far about these prophecies it is
said that the person will be born after
a long summer beneath the bleeding star
amidst salt and smoke when the cold
breath of Darkness falls upon the world
the person will wait dragons from Stone
and wield a burning sword called light
bringer according to the books the
figure would be a Targaryen a descendant
of Aerys the second in Raiola in fact
Danny's older brother Rhaegar was
thought by many to be the prince that
was promised that was before he got her
also the books and the recent season of
the show provided some clarification on
the gender of this figure the prince who
is promised will bring the dawn your
grace
forgive me but your translation is not
quite accurate that's known has no
gender in high Valyrian so the proper
translation for that prophecy would be
the prince or princess and if we look at
the birth of Danny's dragons as the
symbolic birth of her as a hero it
definitely looks like Daenerys is
fulfilling this prophecy this symbolic
birth would be occurring at the end of a
summer beneath a bleeding star remember
the red comet that appears in the sky
shortly after this in season two
it's definitely amidst the smoke of
Drogo's funeral pyre though we would
need a CSI crew to see if we can find
any salt in these ashes maybe the
saltiness of her tears for Drogo or
Mary's tears but she definitely awakens
dragons from stone and of course an
heiress is a descendent of Eris the
second rail all she's really missing is
a burning sword which some believe could
be a metaphor for Jon Snow now of course
he's also a Targaryen descendent yeah I
know a lot of incest going on here and
given the amount of times he's come back
from death one time from the power of
the Lord of Light religion where does or
Ahai prophecy stems from you can
definitely make a case with Jon be in
this figure too
ultimately it seems like the show is
setting up both of these heroes to
jointly service that prophesied heroes
then again part of me thinks the show
won't really spend too much of its final
six episodes on this chosen one prophecy
leaving it maybe as some interesting
background for these characters to defy
and forge their own paths that said the
fact that this moment at least paints
Daenerys Targaryen as the frontrunner to
be a prophesied hero to save the world
suggests her storyline isn't just a B
story or a distraction from the main
narrative on Westeros rather her story
is the one we're meant to focus on and
in a show where characters frequently
staged spectacles to steal the spotlight
the birth of Daenerys dragons might be
the most powerful a question for you
guys which character do you see is more
heroic in Game of Thrones Daenerys or
John I'm honestly split on this they've
both suffered launched themselves in
harm's way repeatedly made tough
unpopular decisions I just go back and
forth on which of them I really badly
behind so I want to know your thoughts
comment down below and tweet me directly
at us we're probably new rockstars on
twitter at new rockstars for updates on
her videos like this video share it
around and subscribe to new rock stars
for all of our Game of Thrones analysis
he could show you my past videos where I
dug into Ned Stark's death and the
golden crown scene Andy dives to do all
the episodes at season 6 & 7 you can
also help this channel by contributing
to us on patreon big thanks to all our
donors especially Kenny Smith thanks for
watching guys bye